Bienvenidos a Easy palestin una
localidad pequeña que hoy por hoy vive
una crisis sanitaria que Escala niveles
nacionales hace ya dos semanas que un
tren descarriló en este pueblo de unos
4.700 habitantes 10 de los vagones que
se volcaron portaban material tóxico
Ted Murphy es un vecino que exhibe como
luce el agua de la zona llegó hace 7
meses pero dice que ya debe volver a
hacer las maletas trabajé hasta el
cansancio para que este lugar luzca como
lo hace y ahora debo mudarme porque no
estoy seguro aquí
para otros vecinos la preocupación no
solo es el agua sino los dolores de
cabeza o la irritación en los ojos que
han empezado a sufrir
esto es peor a lo que cualquiera pensaba
la gente en el pueblo tiene miedo tienen
miedo yo tengo miedo
desde el gobierno Estatal informaron
este viernes que los monitoreos sobre la
calidad del aire y del agua del
Acueducto de hispalesting arrojaron
resultados positivos y no hay razones
para preocuparse incluso
desde la propia casa blanca defendieron
su estrategia en medio de unas críticas
que aparecen ya en el mismo congreso
estamos comprometidos con apoyar al
pueblo de ispalestin en cada paso del
camino vamos a estar en el terreno
ayudándoles todo el tiempo que sea
necesario de momento la presencia sobre
el terreno de un alto funcionario del
gobierno se reduce a la de Michael
Reagan director de la agencia de
protección ambiental el estado de Ohio
anunció que desde la otra semana abrirá
una clínica para atender a quienes
presenten síntomas además El Ejecutivo
Federal enviará médicos y toxicólogos
para colaborar en las labores de
recolección y examen de muestras